the boot in the 50s and 60s a lot of
African-Americans moved northward and
then the industry died and now they're
just stuck up there
Kristen Z
Christy it's parents are right over to
the right yes
hopefully Kristen has some strong
opinions
about the economic downturn in the
Midwest
Christian
I see
where are you from
South Texas
your Brands yes
a lot of Mexicans are
oh ah
sorry about that
a Latina on the show this is happened
multiple times
there's a lot of you guys out there what
what do you think is about Latinas
Latinos
that makes them so freaking sexy
muchos
amore
okay are you single
wow
an actual single person this means
someone has a chance to win better
yeah somebody in this somebody has a
chance to get her wet back tonight you
guys oh
first you said slip now you you're
calling a Mexican woman's A wet
back
this is really offensive I mean you're
not selling anybody's tonight
they brought a box of it it's in the
green room and it's taken out of too
much space it's really unseen way
there's 13 more boxes outside I have to
get them all loaded up
Kristen
seems like you would have a lot of
experience with boxes being Mexican
she loved it she everyone needs to laugh
or else sounds weird
what's your most Mexican thing about you
um
helpful
you have a food truck
isn't it my family
did you grow up in a neighborhood with
an elote man yeah
[Music]
hola
gracias
I want to grab yourself are you looking
for a man that can speak Spanish yeah
she wants an idiot just wants to talk
about him in front of me
you can't hold white guys
Los pantalones
you guys know
what no Spanish
we call this comedians are you all
interested yes where everyone's
interested in Latinas and it's not a
thing that someone's not interested in
Latinas have you ever met racism before
in the dating pool
yeah yeah well it must be nice
because I have okay
and it's okay because I wouldn't want to
be happy
anyways a lot of sexy Asian guys out
there you know I'm just not one of them
but you know I have sex in some ways
right Michael uh you have a very strong
chin like I don't have a chin like here
so I got a little candidate about my
family name or
no I'm a yeah well let's find a man for
Kristen she's single
doesn't mean but as a consent she is
single Dylan Slaughter
a man
oh
never mind
cartoonish hole of the chair
good job we're taking somebody Sam take
him in right now beautiful white man
that's okay sounds like a Home Depot
right now
Dylan
seconds
right now
what are we supposed to do for 90
seconds she's gonna have sex with each
other
ah
well I'm from Michigan actually I'm from
Detroit
if you have on the wrong date how are
you girls just ruin the first 90 seconds
I'm the perfect guy for this girl
yeah I agree with you
in the country but I think without them
went uh when I was like
when I first started drinking anything I
mean this is a perfect thing to like
drink and drive too it's always makes
you sad it's very nice yeah when did you
come to Austin oh February actually I
moved out here I actually live with my
van so it's like it might be the deal
it's like it might be it's like having
sex in a sauna it just
especially right now yeah it's pretty
rough that's why
yeah always you know I almost wore my
Speedo but it's just not acceptable
[Music]
question I'm just gonna ask her if she
was in the little wieners
like that's our first thing I do I think
every time I go on a date I'm like I
have a job but I'm homeless I'm thinking
about a lot of money I think I'm the
perfect guy for years
I don't know
you know the Princeton see Dylan hitting
her arm with the van and the small thing
what's up girl you trying to get some
beef some Little D in the bag
in an automobile
what uh what's one of your strong suits
uh just my personality I'm like bad at
everything else like sports I'm really
good at drinking today when like a
compilation personality makes you tell
the women that you have a small dick you
live in a van yeah yeah that I think
it's funny you have the confidence you
have the confidence of a guy with a
horse and a mansion okay
hahaha
yeah turn it around say the opposite of
what you mean yeah actually you live in
a castle I have a 19 inch what's up
yeah I think it would be like sad for
him to like find out your shorts are
really short
is that uh band thing or yeah I don't
like being hot so I think Jimmy's trying
to never mind what kind of underwear do
you wear oh there's just a line happy
boss service no there's a line I don't
know I hope you're going commando yeah
so you're just ready for sex yeah yeah
one emotion you're there
how many uh so what's the bathroom and
like hygiene situation like you got some
piss jugs in that van or what there's
only one piss Jack nice
are you like a Janet or a Tesla
so I like to name drop Tesla and I'm
like no I just wouldn't you work
physically at the location
[Music]
it sounds good yeah that's the kind of
19-inch energy
what do you do for work I'm a mortgage
lender there we go oh she's white as
much she's wider than you you're working
construction that's where people's stuff
yeah she's like making Mexican
people homeless fake loans or whatever
I'm sure you're a great mortgage lender
I know so many amazing mortgage lenders
in my life they're all great people
I don't know I don't know they're
definitely not the Demons of society
folks I mean we're just trying to get
you into um
[Music]
you put them in a home he's still gonna
have a piss job
hell yeah just fat just empty fabuloso
jugs everywhere with that handle on it
you know what I'm talking about Hans you
had a band did you how many piss jokes
did you have I had one here we go you
know those oil containers they put all
that oil cooking oil in
clear ones I fill it up sometimes
because I'd be lazy nice but I pour it
out there'd be Gunk on the bottom
hell yeah
lots of sonys
[Music]
anyways Kristen have you ever peed in a
bucket
you've never been to Lollapalooza
what what's like the craziest
drug night that you've had
um I haven't participated in them but I
thought
all that meth yeah what's the voted
choice in South Padre Island okay
you guys are the bridge to Mexico
they've got easy access
oh you guys have so much in common
what would be your ideal place to do
cocaine on the count of three answer at
once one two three arcade
you're just fine that's got the claw
machine
so you want that Pikachu or what I'm
pretty sure I could get it
some kids traumatized
let's play DDR right now
what game do you like to play after you
do a buckle coaching it's all like the
glass on the pinball is just perfect
that's on a slant yeah my man's doing
lines off the Star Wars episode
one pinball machine you know the jar jar
being seasons
that's fine Chris if you didn't say
anything where do you do cocaine
regularly
but if you're familiar with where the
Grand Valley is but it's right next to
uh the Rio Grande River
uh two neighboring City it's called
so if you were to go to either one of
those you could probably do a good pit
in one of those and then grab some good
tacos after that so you're incredibly
immediatrician
visors for Mexicans
like if you want a real Mexican weekend
try getting a bubble cocaine and going
again
well that's cool you don't really do
drugs you're uh born to mortgage lending
than Carter basically
oh yeah
that's the kind of girl that Dylan needs
he's like a wild man he has a boxers
yes
oh you want to get hit with a chancleta
okay
spank me what the Target
slippers
Jesus Christ
[Music]
come here come here uh George butcher
so uh Dylan what kind of women do you do
date like Bobby figures
uh no I actually like in Michigan like
where I grew up like it was just all
Republicans it was terrible but uh
that's Sebastian a conservative
here yeah
what's the most craziest thing that your
Republican girlfriends believed I wish
did she invade the capital
yeah that was mostly conspiracy theories
and then like a lot of races like you
can say around but no problem
Kristen are you uh can you say in
South Padre Island
this is being recorded
it's a mortgage lending company
it's actually called mortgage literacy
yeah
how about a mortgage literacy if you
want to find the best cocaine in South
Padre and some tacos
so uh yeah you uh you who do you usually
date do you date like cartel members
no
oh nice some of them
all that vanilla yeah once you go Manila
you wish you went with someone from
Manila are you sure guys
if you guys had a kid it would be a
vanilla
that was good
for a minute yeah it's been in there for
years just never had the proper context
of driving that one
Kristen
um so what kind of white guys like frat
Friday dudes are like
almost
so like lacrosse players
as long as they've got colored eyes
whoa that sounds racist
I like my eyes colored hey we have
colored eyes if you think about it that
brown doesn't come Dylan are you
athletic uh no no I'm not I I used to
like wrestle with Juju Jitsu and now I
just uh do comedy with drunk could you
show us a jiu jitsu move uh
let's choke her out real quick
okay
is that right to use your Jiu Jitsu have
you ever had to fight someone off to
defend your woman's on yeah actually
like I was a door guy it was a lot of
fun like like crackheads
but let me try out my Google Plus on
here yeah to my truck okay
God
you're like I control your hips I
control your penis dude
uh no no like it was intimidating at
first and they'd turn around they'd look
at me like oh she's white dude glasses
it's too scary okay a white dude just
glasses have historically done a lot of
horrible yeah I've been told that
it looked like Jeffrey
oh you did very creepy glasses high five
glasses
you know uh yeah the mustache do get a
lot of like weird comments to people
that you hang around libraries and
daycares yeah I just tend not to like
this has been a rough month with pride
going on they're like you were just like
the guy that did all the oh
yeah
Kristen any questions for Dylan and his
wife yes
I'm actually really nervous and
everybody's sweating profusely well
you've done amazing I think you're very
likable I love a gentleman wow
okay it wasn't smart enough
what is your time foreign
[Applause]
Billy Ray Griffin
did it rain it's your ass up here
it's fun guys
he's a king of the red
oh yeah oh I know that's better
I read about time Tony wants to have sex
with couches
so we opened
Billy Ray Griffin and Jonah from Billy
Ray guys
it's hot what's your favorite way to
date someone
um in person
you know like online
um
what do you say to girls online hi hi
that's not good enough yeah you up
do you have a pulse
wow these are all striking and opening
lines no you should just ask them up
interesting things but they can see
okay
what do you like
um
I like MMA I like comedy uh oh gosh let
me guess you've moved here six months
ago
two months
[Music]
what's your favorite podcast
you live in a van
what SUVs
they're a dime a dozen things I don't
know why they keep coming here
I mean
I I also used to live in a van
we gotta sing in Texas let's go back to
wherever you came from it's uh yeah go
back to your van
so
you're you're a van life in Florida
talk about swamp day
how much how many key bottles did you
have to have
meatballs yeah his jokes I just
want
Ah that's strange
living that strike life
every time you piss you're like risking
a felony
I ended up getting bitten off by a
Gatorade that little worm
dancing out there for him dog you can't
be dude man have you ever yeah the
alligator to buy your anaconda and a
anaconda don't one
that's Hassan
Philly so uh how would you uh find your
way over here are you uh you were in
Florida you're like hey let me why don't
I go somewhere with people that are
slightly smarter oh comedy yeah uh I was
on probation last year wow for what lady
I'm not a really good drug dealer what
extension to you yes
you're doing the Lord's work man
make sure it's out there pedaling your
craft getting arrested how much you get
charged with it was I saw an ounce to a
chicken with
yeah it wasn't even a legendary it's
just a chicken he's like I can pick
something now I'd pick something
station a better police oh and big boobs
now so she was like I don't know what
the idiot that I want to
another
day
this is what Florida's like man don't go
to Florida it's horrible yeah what's
your favorite part of Florida
um besides the I can't go to
Legoland why you know we already knew
that from your face
and your shorts
uh angle man you got tags at Legoland
why can't you go to Legoland
um because uh you can't go
more than loser dudes
we have to team together we'd go
together can we go together yeah we can
find it we'll dress you up we'll dress
you up like the kid we'll get you the
little hat with the propeller on it into
atomically large popsicles
no I'm not the kid I'm the mom
okay I'm the most feminine looking one
out of all three of us there's long
enough yeah I have a great
what's your favorite thing to do in on a
date do you like to uh pull the chair
out for ladies
um yeah chair open the door nice oh
beautiful flowers I like flowers
what's so weird that you would bring
flowers to a sit-down Pizza Hut date you
know what I mean like I said I love
pizza
that's the only place open okay so uh
whichever like get flowers for a woman
at the wrong time
have you ever done that before yeah in
high school
but you gave it to the CI that arrested
you for weed
no Steve having her she
doesn't want it yeah last time you gave
a girl flowers you got in trouble dude
yeah some guy you joking me his flower
you got in jail no I didn't not
that time oh Billy Ray was in
jail
well it's got a woman up here
lucky woman yeah I was just about to say
a man Amanda a man
amazing
[Applause]
thank you
I actually don't drive all right
okay
you like anime
[Applause]
oh yeah
throw it up
Cheesecake Factory I with
cheesecake cheesecake factory
give it up for autism on the Spectrum
oh my God you saw for Billy rizz
trying to feel a yeah
I gotta handicapper
all right so you have no return there
um it's interesting you you started out
with Dad jokes I think you have to
become a dad first
you can't just open yet hey I'm not
reproduced
anyways
Amanda what's uh your dating history
like
um
you counted your boyfriends yeah oh
[Applause]
you're the only one on stage that has
sex
awesome uh
no I'm not saying with three boyfriends
yes you're a in the question
what why did it work out with number one
it's not your middle school
so
you had a boyfriend in middle school was
he at about Billy Ray's intelligence
level
okay what is something you can bring to
the table in a relationship that you
don't pick her other three boyfriends
besides flowers
eats and crayons
um
little is my favorite
[Applause]
motivation of us interesting boyfriend
probably one head in jail
my second boyfriend
girls just be breaking up with
man I don't know
get away no no he was
I think he was a cheater I don't know
for sure but what made you think he was
a cheater I founded a girl's character
and his apartment oh he's cheap
[Music]
whoa he's gone with the previous tenant
yeah
it's impressive property
was it a lesbian before ever before you
guys
I don't know well let's just wear
haircuts
and they just kind of shaved it looked
like Molly right yeah
Billy Ray uh
you like to eat
that's what he calls the
soon to go out back you know what I'm
saying yeah I
have a lot of girls
yeah it's like getting your own car back
in your old car back yeah like
remodeling oh yeah
uh
Amanda yeah what's like your favorite
thing to do in the background
I like sleeping
for me I don't mind
[Applause]
it's already slipping you know what I
mean
Ray
Amanda what's the uh
so what's a turn off for you like a a
special thing that other people aren't
turned on by like autistic people
I apologize
um I don't know I'm like
foreign
[Applause]
I know
what do you think it'd be like
[Music]
just like that oh yeah that's a good
feeling man
you uh how do you get that feeling of
normal everyday life you ride bird
scooters
I could barely even walk I'm not gonna
do that
you drive
barely you can't walk but you try
to drive
legally you can drive if you can see it
you can drive all right that's what my
daddy told me and his daddy told me it
burned I think this is a good morning
you can literally register anything in
Florida you could make your own car in
Florida and put a weed whacker
motor on a shopping cart and
plates for it I saw a guy get a DUI on a
lawn mower
on the experience
is there a pool to Craftsman over take
the keys out
this is a Target parking lot what are
you talking about
that's where I sleep
it's a good place to sleep
Amanda have you ever been arrested
no
what's the hardest drug I've ever done
at 23 years old don't say pot
I don't know there we go just focused as
yeah pretty sure oh can I return her
are you vaccinated
no comments
you're not vaccinated are you
um
what do you think about people that get
vaccinated
yeah your body your choice am I right
ladies
go vaccinated don't be an idiot
Amanda what's like uh what's your
favorite part of living in Texas
what about the guys are they different
here yeah they're very different they're
extremely different they're autistic
yeah and kind they're nice
that's cool where are you from New York
City
um
pizza right yeah yeah that's cool
Billy's
Billy's name
New York City what noise would you make
there
where are you going that fast
what do you know about the Earth dude
um Saturday lives there yeah
the Big Apple I think that's just the
name nickname I don't think there's
actually an animal
is there an Apple Amanda in New York
his entire reality is like yeah there's
a big app in there yeah where do you
think in New York the Big Apple would be
like what street
you're mad why wouldn't it be in
Manhattan
it's too big a million Billy's next
question is going to be have you met
Spiderman
yeah are there any questions you'd like
to ask Amanda about the big city
um have you ever gotten milk there no no
Billy Ray wishing Amanda's safety
any advice from Billy Ray if he ever
goes to New York
um
discounted Subway tickets
we're like Hey Y'all how you doing
yo dead ass go practice
I saw your weed an ounce of it
yeah you got big boobs
well
what do you guys have to say
yeah I think I think you're very sweet
too yeah
all right
that's definitely not getting laid
yeah
um
I'm just kidding
um Billy Ray thank you for being on the
show uh
that's gonna stay up here
welcome back to a giant table of Asians
that's got a very important business
meeting he's got a schedule
are you at mortgage lending as well
or do they do you just have that that
Polo
yeah
mortgage Landing pillow I've ever seen
yes I love
it the fact that you said I promise
makes you think that you're a shady
mortgage ladder
Eastern European accent
hello
and Drop Shipping like Dropship limit
illegal every food
John Wicks together
I have beaches inside of shooting
container for you at 16 beaches one book
right now
he's got benches he needs to be on his
phone
well maybe he'll go on a date with a
beautiful lgbtqia plus man or woman or
whatever remain
a person oh this is for me my friend
I love this song
to the show my friend you look like
you're being shady Morgan's lender as
well yeah a shady landlord um
you sound like you don't look like it's
all dodgy dodgy Gyros
okay sell perfume at the mall look at
this what would you do if you met this
guy at the moment
but like it was the douchiest of the
douche I tried to storm cologne or like
a cell phone plan
oh it's so fun you look like you need a
fresh new Android
nice that works back in the motherland
too right
two cards
he is currently plotting to
have a skills
his texting is Goods
watch out of bed with sweatpants come in
the door
uh Romina what's the game what's
Gangster thing that you've done most
gangster thing that I've done yeah I've
never shot someone
uh
Global building no I uh used to sell the
drugs probably
gangster you didn't get caught like
Billy Ray now I'm not an amateur
I'm sorry the women with small titties
but anyways
you uh you you uh were a successful weak
salesman yeah
retired now nice because I'm an adult is
that why you have two marks on your
eyebrow for every year you stole drugs
no
[Music]
what's your favorite pickup line to the
ladies uh
hey I think you're attractive whoa that
works do you think I'm attractive it
actually does yeah okay well you have to
be attractive for that one yeah like all
right thank you I am attractive but no I
don't think you're a bird then you move
on and yeah find out early instead of
two years in exactly
you're just swiping right on everyone in
real life
it was some thick skin
yeah what's the most hurtful thing a
girl said about you that you look like
you sell perfume at a mom
like uh
the most personal thing probably like I
don't want to sleep with you uh I hit it
with a woman say that it's so sad
how many do you call it the Dead
Sea screws
just rubbing hands putting
lotion on all the time I hate those
have you ever had sex with two girls at
the same time with 9 11.
to some elevator shafts
yeah well no threesome no not yet okay
so who do you want to date uh we got men
and women
um it's real 300. there's no other lgbtq
plus people now you want to just be
asexual on stage
uh anyone gay or
straight I want to go on a date for 90
seconds with ramine orange shirt in the
back right there the rug seller and yeah
orange shirt come on up
I don't stress
yes aren't stress coming up
she is sitting with a man who I hope
it's her brother
but it's orange dress coming up oh I
know orange dress it's Angela
comedian coming up for Angela
90 seconds starting now
uh I'm in a relationship so I'm
basically okay
yeah you're bisexual so you lean towards
guys or girls more I mean statistically
guys but romantic girls like I treat
girls way better who do you like being
in bed with more guys or girls
yeah
because I can like recall some girls in
college so I was like drop everything
forward okay it was like the best sex
you've ever had in your life is it a guy
or a girl as a guy okay let's go men
hold it down oh yeah
so uh do you think I'm attractive
um
oh yeah so what do you do with your life
to make a lot in Parks really
absolutely thrilling really I like to be
alone a lot I don't have a lot of
friends but I do like to get up I
do a lot of tracks nice you sound like a
very fun person I like that like the
days I'm alone I'm like I'm super alone
I don't
do itself but the days I'm out like my
vendors
okay seven days a week how many days are
you reading how many days are you on
drugs
[Music]
give it up for the worst
a teenage run away in her chapter ladies
and gentlemen
a trafficker and a traffic key
s
traffic
your favorite drug is my phone
uh rameen you you uh went on a date you
gave Ben a shout out in the middle of
the date yeah we have good sex
supposedly
oh we're gonna have the population yeah
it's kind of a broad shout out
um you will open the date up with I'm in
a relationship are you just trying not
to
no I'm trying to bring somebody trouble
they got threesome happening
so what does she look like
um she's a female
uh she's brown like me but she's Indian
you can just say Indian yeah well some
are later some are darker
Brown yeah it's a brown
you like Browns yeah okay she's a brown
house
everyone's Brown dude yeah I think it
doesn't work
what's up
random people are they more tropical
you are
I think that's pretty true
[Music]
Northerners yeah
what's uh what's the throttle gonna look
like is it a one-time thing you guys are
just gonna go in the bedroom and
roll around
um
[Music]
but yeah it sounds like a good plan so
you just go into a date say I'm in a
relationship I kind of want to roll
around with you like where's the
direction what
I'm here then if I introducer my
girlfriend and then we can both go on a
date on like a three-way game have you
been on any three-way dates yes
well I mean not dates but like
no you need book sessions
they're looking for brain brings her to
the apartment the girlfriend's like oh
this one's pretty pretty
stress some little dickies yeah
it's like I've never been on a date that
wasn't arranged by my parents
right
now
yeah Angela's jealous now no no I like
girls with big boobs geez everyone does
some big old Indian Builders baby
basically the girl that I sleep with
some of those otters we have insurance
in common getting off to a great start
how old are you I'm 22 . nice God bingo
Angela what's the uh craziest
drug party that you've been to
uh it wasn't a party but it was me and
this guy and we dropped acid it was one
of those bus sessions yeah but it was
like an eight-hour one
um
four tabs of acid and four uh was he
just coming battery acid probably I
don't recall
intense yeah Ramin what's the uh what's
the craziest drug sex that you've had
I uh smoked pot and then I came in like
three minutes nice I love that when that
happens
too that's crazy last of them yeah dude
there they go play marathons
so Ramin you're uh pretty conservative
are your parents in your life
from appearance in my life holy I
just think it's funny
okay
that's it
I called the corner of the room
[Applause]
it's a drone
ourselves
that's the scariest language to start
talking in your clothing
Putin Vladimir
I'm in the terrible
yeah let me call my drone guy real quick
one second we stand with Russia
Ukraine
thank you for wearing your dress clothes
to a comedy show hopefully there's a
water cooler talk later
uh Angela what's the uh what's the
craziest like does your have you ever
been like a normal date like that your
mom set up oh oh God no my mom tries to
get people like marry me and
you know
honestly censor up with Billy Ray
[Music]
coming back from the crowd The Legend
Continues the backstory believes putting
a flag in the land
don't worry you got it Angela's
having sex with dudes for eight hours
good God yeah I was 19. he won I said I
remember when I was 19.
um no this was like two weeks ago oh we
could still smell him
Romina have you ever had sex for a long
time
just wondering you just jerk off like
three times before you sleep in the
morning
there you go last a long time yeah
you can also stab yourself in the eye
no just kidding ramine is sexually
experienced what country are you from
um here I am oh yeah you know those
Iranian man not for there
good sexual freedoms yeah he's got a
weapon of mass destruction you know what
I'm talking about
got that giving you that wmd you know
what I'm saying stuff got that Camel
deck
dude drinks a ton of water stores
it in his bag
Adventure
I don't know I don't like I was from a
small town I didn't like living in a
small town so you just had no plans well
my family was like my brother lives
they're a small town girl living in a
lovely world took a midnight train
there's no trains in Texas oh it wasn't
that kind of train ladies and gentlemen
it was multiple men to midnight train it
was black dudes today was uh what per
hour
you don't like MMF
o
there you go
as soon as mine that's the way you
should do it honestly this is going
great
hell yeah
Romaine in a what's your relationship
with your Indian like
[Music]
it's a relationship
perfectly circular is it like a sticker
I think they just like dip it in red
paint or ink I don't know I don't know
okay it's not very thankful if you don't
know who she wouldn't you're gonna put a
you ever put a dot on her forehead you
know what I'm saying
just one
whoa it's really hard
but man uh any crazy sex moves that you
think Angela would be impressed by
any crazy uh
I don't know she's bi any crazy sex
moves oh yeah this is a good one uh you
take them and you have her head like
hanging off the bed uh have her open her
mouth and then you just
yeah so it's mostly about you getting
your dick sides
just yes
ah yes
really you're looking me like head
laying off the edge of the bed and then
another little doggy yeah there you go
that's what you're doing her out while
her was playing her off a bit yeah see
how she tilt her head she's like oh yeah
is this what you're doing with your
intelligence is like figuring out
different three-way configurations you
could be doing math right now yeah
he's doing geometry dawg I thought
you're gonna be like my craziest sex
movies when I have another guy come in
and me in the ass that's a good one
dude am I crazy my craziest sex move is
when my wife's like yeah sure
oh
no does he just turn over no turn over
you know when girls are lazy and they
just like crying
I hate to inform you but you guys damn
victims now you do this thing called
gorilla so like I put both of my
feet on the bed and her legs Gorilla
Glue in her because you stay there
for hours
hey if you don't have Lube
good God
what a wonderful image you just painted
I'm making crystals
so well uh Romaine what do you uh have
to say to Angela tonight
uh it was very nice meeting you
too
oh is that a very Brown thing with a
left-handed handshake
Jesus Christ
I thought Angela was gonna go deal
put this on your forehead
anyways
[Applause]
[Music]
we got massively excellent straight down
so I swear to us
[Applause]
came to the stage that's another one
yeah that's the name of the magazine new
album
wow very informative you're very smart
you know it's I feel like you're my dad
right now
so like we got caught at a sleepover
doing whippets
you're very fatherly like you're like
what the hell is going on over here oh I
got two kids yeah you do that yeah yeah
you have the body of like your ancestors
are just carrying treats like for
thousands of years yeah
it's no you're not affected by snow
he has hair yes
this is like Ivan Drago
what do you think you want to say to the
Wagner group right now
good answer yeah
it's denied to nine to nine sure have
you ever been interrogated
what's gonna happen
I gotta kill you
okay
yeah we're autistic
have you ever talked to someone that
doesn't kill people for a living
um
dude your arms are as big as my legs
yeah I'm nervous
drugs that came into the Olympic
athletes Russia
what's the manliest thing that you've
done oh
besides the ice Plunge
um
well honestly
I lost my phone
oh yeah
Susie is he like so you're Russian I'm a
half Russian Football here
oh okay so he's like oh you go to get to
this country you think you're better
than everybody huh like that oh which is
offensive oh you want McDonald's french
fries okay all right
look how granular the detail is on my
shirt
oh you have name brand grocery you
Pizza get your paper yeah
functioning uh electricity running water
you
it's not a third world country it's a
beautiful place it's two and a half
hours
how do you want to solve these problems
with your arms
anyways you're here to date are you
single
um
I am yeah you have to think about it not
well
I'm I'm separated like
emotionally a lot of it
does she know that you're emotionally
out of it or does she still think you're
married
oh my God
so you're just that
oh well you like that you might be yeah
maybe you'll meet someone tonight that
you can be respectful towards that's
fine too
so let's let's meet this lucky lady
hopefully you don't end up dead
I'm nervous don't piss him off
don't burn the chicken
we got Leo in
coming in from the table
that has been past the show so far
yeah big shout out to this group right
here you guys have been great keep it up
for these people
they don't have gone on a date with
massive America for 19 seconds starting
out yeah
nice to meet you thank you for asking me
on a date
thanks for asking how are you doing yeah
I dropped myself you know I met a new
friend today um
[Music]
um what do you do for fun
for fun uh what we already said about
the ice baths
I recently started running a lot across
the field
for fun um I also do ice baths
what's the longest you've ever seen
yesterday I did seven
[Applause]
minutes
I like to go like Travis you know I go
with my kids
cool
um are your kids nice surprise
the boys hello
I don't have any children anytime you go
to Brazilian and maximum
you could tell how manly Maximus because
his hand is always near his dick
you're just ready to jerk it or
something and he got out of his chair to
shake her hand that was also like a
clutch gentleman thing I just have a
quick question for you guys in your
group are you all couples
you're just a bunch of single people
hanging out
the prophecy
this is Dawson's Creek or a WB show and
I know you guys are it's so
frustrated you know
you're frustrated well we only just met
so
um
giant orgy
anyways uh just one Russian guy and two
Asian guys watching them cameraman
we're the main characters
um so you do CrossFit
you put the emphasis on the second word
CrossFit
um
these are stupid accent
hey would you like to speak to other
languages
I know Korean
comes like that
you actually Mash
this is a Korean I don't want to
read the news fake ass Arena
when I work with three parts of North
Korea
yeah you Chinese
so I will never come together as a race
of people patience or just always
telling you
do employ your social credit score
jaywalking I'm Filipino I can't get
involved
the more loving agents
yeah but you don't have a GDP no
we do have uh heavy numbers in STD
though we have a lot of STD in the
Philippines
that's cool you got your own thing going
on
how this next door is toys
hey Madison
uh have you been on a lot of sex tourism
oh no
Heather what do you do with all that
money you get from strangling nerds
I'm listening
and I said what do you do for work North
Wisconsin
oh nice so you work for a Korean company
thank you
[Applause]
open Gangnam Style
mail in now you're impressed by uh this
polyglot
I am
congratulations
a lot of Google going on right now
what how many languages can you speak I
am speak
while I'm learning Spanish so only one
uh I thought he would speak to the dead
or something oh really yeah are you like
like a psychic here in tool yes people
always tell me that I've tried to speak
to the spirits but
no answer
just keep getting ripped off by that
Crystal at the farmers market yeah
don't you like that yeah
well as soon it seems like you're very
much more in tune with the Earth and uh
you know like having empathy and human
emotions and maximum
this is like a psychopath
thank you you're gonna set him off in
any direction he'll kill whoever he has
to very transactional
yeah I'm glad you're on our side on
Samsung
what do you do for Samsung
uh there's a new project going over to
Taylor and oversee the construction I
don't know if uh to install makes any
sense to you but uh
equipment that makes the chips receive
the process of installation protection
and construction yeah is that why you're
wearing a
thing you can go into a wet room then
less coordinated in charge of computer
instruction
s he's got a good job he has a teeth
he's a foreign
yeah it's impressive seems like he's on
a good path he doesn't hurt people right
anymore
that's delicious economically
yeah how did it go toughest thing I have
to do okay fire me right now
I got fired a lot it's okay you can fire
me all you want I've been fired many
times go for it dude you need it
on a fight for me it's a good job
Phillip dude I get drunk on the forklow
dude are you sure
absolutely sure I screamed the n-word in
the warehouse are you sure dude
hydraulic Instagram
thanks for not doing anything yeah thank
you for not firing with God me and my 17
Filipino children that I cannot feed
them
just featured me as like a minority that
you don't want around anymore
that's pretty easy Bulgaria
and he's thrown the forklifts they say
inwardly
so you uh and you have a cool job uh
what do you think is like the key to uh
being successful
uh consistency hard work
look at yourself very Eastern European
answers there we go yeah
born and raised have you ever traveled
I do spend quite a bit of time in Mexico
okay I guess I'm an immigrant there
right yeah
I think you're just uh tourists well I
have a temporary Mexican residency
actually
and you don't know Spanish well I'm
learning Spanish okay it's just taking a
while
what's uh and I definitely can't speak
in on the spot in Spanish do you ever
talk to like the fruit vendors I do yeah
how does that usually go you don't call
the cops on them do you no okay you're
white I have to ask you don't really
talk to the cops in Mexico why not
you're not really there to help you uh
she's got me Shake You Down yeah you're
an American oh you know we can just be
like uh you're in a non-white Zone give
me 250 bucks
just like the motherland yeah
I can relate
have you ever called the cops on a
minority
of course the cups
[Applause]
also yeah I love you in the movies I've
seen a lot of you guys
what's your stereotype of Russians and
uh have you ever dated a Russian before
I've never heard Russian
but that's good though you like you know
you took the uh negative energy of your
father and now you're transferring it
into positive energy for your two sons
and I think that makes you a very
marketable man you know what I'm saying
but uh be loser so
you're false bro
that's the reality want that
felony dig I don't know if you notice
and for the streets dog
well it seems like you got both you seem
like kind of like a violent scary person
and also a nice decent person so yes
it's your eyes
you're the eyes of somebody who's broken
fingers
how many steps
Lillian have you ever heard somebody
mortally I probably know
it's like what's like something that you
regret like some tough one that you've
heard on accident
oh I mean no regrets no regrets yeah I
mean everything happens for a reason
right
oh I can't I can't think of the spot I
haven't heard anyone
peace
that's good son you have that wild side
in front of your house
all these people in bands man I don't
have a man
all right so what kind of what is it
like what is what's that is a car man
what I don't have nothing no
oh man you are the streets you guys help
me I got a bunch of like
is there like a Groupon or how'd you
guys all means yes uh authentic relating
wow that's hard to do nowadays
is that what is that it's talking about
your feelings and strangers
oh nice
yeah I do statue it's called the
treatment I can't open mic and uh
nobody's here
is here just me taking my uh taking my
clothes off
please buy this merch he needs it I
swear to God I need it uh
excellent uh
you you seem like a very serious guy do
you ever like uh do acting or like music
or like no multiple times occasionally
what do you do to relax and have fun yo
got it the reason it's coming to yoga
affection oh Leo it definitely does yoga
I do here
I love that I do do yoga
well you guys uh
want to trade yoga tips with each other
after the show
yeah sure sure
a little something sexy sounds exciting
thank you thank you for that suggestion
Leon is embodying that she wants that
downward dog if you get what I'm saying
close
I don't think that's what she was a play
I'm trying to help everybody here
everybody should get laid yeah
yeah maybe uh massive could do some
downward dog only went to do some upward
dog
roll the mats out
well give it up for leolin if that's
there
[Applause]
yeah
right Russian couple he's very strict
she was very quiet
just like it's supposed to be
we just made out
whoa
[Applause]
um
the overview Style
he's about to get on the phone and be
like home please
[Applause]
[Music]
another show what'd you think Michael
what'd you have to say I loved it I
think we had a really good time I've
done this a couple times with you I
always loved being here thank you guys
here but thank you guys for coming
[Applause]